[Music]
since it was first revealed in 2017
Metro Exodus has emerged as one of the
most eagerly anticipated gaming
prospects of 2019 this third installment
of 4a games distinctive first-person
survival shooter takes place two years
after the events of Metro last light and
promises to take us on a journey beyond
the desolate tunnels of post-apocalyptic
Russia we've experienced so far here are
the reasons we're very excited to
re-enter the ravaged world of the Metro
series after two games spent exploring
Moscow's maze-like Underground system
hero Artyom has now hitched a ride on
Aurora a modified steam train on a
journey to find life beyond the metro
joining him on this quest along the
trans-siberian railway are returning
characters Anna and Miller alongside a
new cast of Spartan Rangers they include
the deceptively named idiot who is
presumably inspired by the protagonist
of the Dostoyevsky novel that shares his
name
now he's made the transition to an
overground transport system Artyom is
going to spend a lot more time exploring
Russia's surface away from the safety of
Aurora he'll have to contend with the
threat of mutants hostile humans natural
environmental dangers and our old friend
radiation poisoning there's also a
persistent day/night cycle so you'll
have to prepare to encounter nocturnal
enemies who will hunt you from the
shadows Metro Exodus hasn't abandoned
the linearity that defined its previous
two installments as it expects from a
game set on a train the story takes
players from location to location on a
fixed route however each location is now
what the game's creators call a sandbox
survival level a vast open space that
can take hours to explore fully you'll
have to scavenge resources survive
against mutants and human enemies and in
a spirit of previous Metro games will
encounter additional quests to distract
you from the task at hand
the method of acquiring weapons in
Exodus has changed significantly
compared to previous metro games new
firearms can now be scavenged from dead
enemies or you can strip their guns for
parts and attachments impressively every
handcrafted weapon is purported to
function in real life such as the
delightfully named bastard gun which
appears to be comprised of parts from a
pipe a bucket some pliers and lots of
imagination
weapons modding has also been expanded
greatly offering five attachments
categories to upgrade and alter
performance namely scope barrel stock
magazine and under barrel the best part
Artyom now has a backpack slung over his
shoulders that contains all the tools
necessary to mod and craft at any time
during his adventure however the world
will not stop around him while he's
tinkering so if you want to prevent
Artyom being swept up by a demon while
he's screwing on a silencer it's
probably best that you first locate a
relatively safe spot gone are the
trading posts of 2033 and last light
which means no more worrying about
footing ammo aside as a currency to
acquire new gear instead there are two
key resources chemicals and materials
the former is used for weapons
maintenance and the latter is essential
for crafting med kits gas masks filters
and ammo for bespoke weapons if you want
to keep the odds in our team's favor
it's going to fade to scavenge every
corner of the world the metro games have
always included an element of choice
with various moments some obvious some
less so impacting on the story's outcome
exodus makes this decision-making a much
more integral part of the experience
giving you freedom to choose how you
tackle situations all guns blazing is
still very much an option but stealthier
approaches can net the same results were
also giving you an opportunity to listen
on other factions conversations and even
if you do ops issues everything in sight
you might find that certain enemies will
surrender giving you dynamic moral
choices do you shoot or do you spare
them you might find that certain spared
foes will come running to your aid as a
critical moment later in the game or
they might just take advantage of your
good nature and have another crack at
killing you
[Music]
as Artyom's horizons expand so -
unfortunately there's the diversity of
mutant enemies eager to tear him apart
joining the returning demons watchman
nozzle is shrimp and lurkers are several
brand new and utterly terrifying
aberrations humanimal czar pack-hunting
mutants who act like rabid apes spiders
are grossly mutated arachnids with an
aversion to light
wolves are well lower wolves but really
hungry and very angry and mutated bears
are just very very very bad news
Metro Exodus runs on forays in-house
engine the very same that powered both
2033 and last lights and one that is
still widely regarded as among the best
in the business
naturally the technology has evolved a
great deal in the 5 years that have
passed since the last game and with
Exodus is much expanded scope the engine
now accommodates a host of new systems
and effects improve lighting superior
textures performance captured facial
animation and dynamic weather systems
all serve to make Exodus the finest
looking Metro to date impressively the
Xbox one X version is promised to
support native 4k resolution with full
HDR
to complement its standout graphics to
Metro Exodus brings photo mode to the
series for the very first time available
from day one photo mode will give
players the chance to document their
adventures from a perspective beyond our
team's headspace and apply their
artistic eye to the twisted beauty of
the Russian wastelands it won't be long
until you can join Artyom and the crew
of the aurora on their epic journey
across post-apocalyptic Russia because
Metro Exodus arrives February 15 2019
[Music]